bring the tackles bring the tacos I'm so
excited all this how are the pizza I
don't know I feel like tacos are great
food because you can just have so many
different kinds of tacos and never get
bored of it breakfast taco that's lunch
tacos tacos a deep deep profound love
for pizza pizza pizza my favorite food
breakfast again breakfast lunch dinner
if I've had like weird dreams about
tacos I've had naughty dreams about
pizza
yes f me up Tony baloney I mean it
smells good like we got everything's
moving right now it's a heavy it's heavy
I can barely lift I feel that that's
like a 10 pound people it's a pizza
shaped box so I guess I'm assuming it's
a taco flavored pizza oh wow are you
kidding me oh I wanna grow a bunch of
vaginas I thought every single one of
these is like a different flavor of top
I thought here smells delicious yeah it
smells both of pizza and taco the first
thing we have to do is to take a chunk
of guacamole to the face is that I'm not
upset about it so the question is to do
it do you still fold it like you're
gonna can fold it also is there is it a
real pizza underneath oh oh that's a
good question honestly how do we eat
this [ __ ] thing
they're beautiful I don't think there's
any rules to how to eat this pieces
breaks every rule I'm going to do an
initial bite a side bite and then I'm
going to grab it with my hands - I am
fine I'm continuing to be lost in the
sauce like maybe you're supposed to
remove the tacos and then dip them in
the Buncombe all there but welcome all
is really expensive and that's how I
like my bottom line every bite is a new
adventure
I like me to get a room with this thing
so good yeah excuse me go to a party
with this you're in immediately
friendship I never thought about putting
a taco on a pizza but now that it's been
done I never want to go back guess who's
having a salad for dinner
god bless Tony baloney thanks Tony I
sound like a broken record with like
breakfast lunch dinner late-night snacks
weddings Bar Mitzvahs oh there's be the
best bar mitzvah food ever
[Music]